[Music]
what about working out what about
exercise um there's the
go run a marathon and if you've ever
been to a marathon you see people of all
body types and then there's the uh
don't ever run cardio again just lift
and then there's the
only do dead lifts and squats and bench
press what are we supposed to do man
i'm talking is the average character
just trying to get a little bit better
at their life
now when it comes to exercise
if you're just looking to get healthier
you know because i my background is i
want to be the most muscular strong
human being i can possibly be and yeah
real quick you you were a bodybuilder so
you did all natural shows which is for
the casual listener that's like all
oiled up uh like pose down right
correct so i've done competitive
bodybuilding and then you hold world
records like in the squat and dead lift
so i've done power lifting as well so
power lifting is squat bench press and
deadlift and i was national champion in
2014 in 2015
qualified for the world championships in
finland in 2015. i got an overall silver
medal there
and i said it was
i set what was then the world squat
record which was uh and i was in the 93
kilogram class which is 205 pounds
and i squatted 668 pounds
um
and so that's you know all drug free and
uh you know just belts and knee sleeves
that's right
that's incredible so that was um
so yeah i've got some so exercise is
different from you for you than it is
for sure for me for sure i want to look
at that on camera i want my wife to
still think i'm hot and
i want the guy down the street walking
his dog to think twice before he like
flexes up on like so what am i supposed
to do man
again
what you will be consistent with right
um the the now i will say i think
resistance training for anybody is about
the healthiest thing you can do because
you'll get cardiovascular benefits from
resistance training if you go hard
enough
um you'll get like it's literally the
best thing for bone density as well
um
you know obviously
if you want to change the way your body
work looks there is nothing more
powerful than resistance training and by
resistance
dr norton is lifting weights lifting
weights yeah lifting weights now what do
you do machines or or compounds or
whatnot listen i love squatting and dead
lifting bench press i'm kind of okay at
so not as not as passionate about that
but you know like for me
like
like today actually um i've been coming
back from some injuries so just before i
got on this podcast i spotted 500 for
five reps which is the first time i've
done that in a couple of years i did 185
suckers how do you like that on my squat
workout this morning nope 195. i added a
five
it's all relative
but uh like me like that's
that's like
that's like like i'm like i got my music
on and i'm like into it i like that when
i'm done i'm like man that's like that's
like the highlight of my week right
there you know yeah but not everybody's
like me so some people love crossfit uh
some people like olympic weightlifting
some people just want to do machines
because it's you know you don't have to
worry about as much stuff listen
whatever will get you in the gym
consistently
is what you should do because if you're
consistent with it
it's impossible not to make progress
over time as long as you are continuing
to apply the principles that you were
using
to get there so i mean again just like
debt right so some people are you know
100 000 in debt
and so they use these principles they
get out of debt well now what's the next
thing how do you progressively overload
that well now we're going to start
saving an emergency fund right and then
well now we're going to start putting
some away from retirement like you're
progressively
improving right so in terms of lifting
weights that's okay like
i've done this thing now i'm going to
add more weight to the bar or i'm going
to do more reps or i'm going to do more
sets right like those are all ways to
progressively overload so if you don't
want to plateau you have to continue to
progress but again whatever form of
exercise gets you in there and you find
fun and you can be consistent with
that's that's what you want to do in
fact for me
i'll have people tell me man you are so
dedicated like you have such good
willpower and i'm like
dude i love this like they take
willpower to keep me out of here you
know what i don't don't think i'm like
some kind of like
amazing
um you know incredible human who just
slogs like listen i have days where i
don't want to go trained i do it anyway
but
for the most part
i love that yeah like that's that's the
highlight of my day right so
and there were seasons in my life when
when i was training them i loved being
in the mma gym and competing i didn't
like lifting weights and then there was
i know people who love to
run love to i love that i feel freeing
dr norton just to say dude just be
consistent
um
and do lift weights am i even seeing
some of the the long distance runners
now
circling back and incorporating
weightlifting as a cornerstone it used
to when i was running it was be as light
as possible
um only sprinters 400 and below need to
be lifting the weights and now
everybody's in on it just good for
everything weightlifting
whatever your sport is weightlifting as
long as you continue to do said sport
weightlifting will just make you better
at that sport i love that they told
basketball players don't lift weights
because you know it's going to mess up
your jump shot whatever and i remember
back when i was in college i remember
one year kobe came out and he was like
10 pounds heavier and he just started
like that was when he really started
taking over and then obviously you see
somebody like lebron james who isn't
like a power lifter but i mean he's a
big dude for an nba player
and there's a reason that like he for
you know a 15-year period most dominant
player in the game is because not just
not only did he have skills he
physically dominated people i know we
have very similar upper bodies me and
lebron uh like if i i wear big shirts on
purpose but if i didn't have my shirt on
our upper bodies are very very similar
um that's not true at all i just i'm i'm
i was like do i call him on this